the Joe Rogan experience if you're
someone that wants to do porn you were
coming off better just setting up your
webcam like Joe Rogan yeah
day one podcast you and Brian with a
laptop and a microphone and just turning
the webcam on and just doing whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do with yourself
then dealing with the industry yeah and
the record industry's becoming similar
to that too
I think so too but I think that it's
hard for them to find an audience that
way there's so much porn like I had a
joke I was doing for a while about why
are they making new porn like who is
jerked off to all of it no way anyone
has seen it all but yet they keep making
new porn it's like it's crazy like
there's no demand like there's no demand
for new stuff that's plenty like you
would have to be some kind of crazy
creep to seen every porn that if ever as
ever existed but it's no different than
MMA there's people innovating people
innovating in porn back flipping and POV
in these scenarios breaking their necks
yeah yeah it's uh I think the the camp
thing is the big thing
girls [ __ ] on camera you know they'll
have the boyfriend come over and they'll
[ __ ] him and suck his dick on camera and
you pay to watch I think that's that's
the big thing and they do private shows
and like the guy could tell you know you
could tell the girl hey I want you to do
this to him and they'll do it on camera
you know the funniest [ __ ] though so
Steve Byrne and I we were in Pittsburgh
and three things lead to another and we
end up at a strip club and it's a
weekend and so a pair I didn't know this
but porn stars tour strip clubs and
they'll go to a strip club on the
weekend and dance and sell whatever
pocket [ __ ] or whatever vagina mole
they have and all of the strippers
[ __ ] the strip is a coup because all
they bring more people into the club but
for the most part the men are saving
that tip money to tip the porn star that
they came to see so it's like being a
seasoned comic and then the Instagram
comic
then who's never stripped before like
yeah you [ __ ] on camera but it's not
stripping what I do is an art what you
do is [ __ ] behave because you know like
there's like a beef between like
strippers and prostitutes because like
some strippers are sucking [ __ ] in the
back of the club and it [ __ ] up money
for the rest of the strippers right that
are yeah they're you know playing the
game straight up right so there was this
weird tension in the strip club fouled
the pornstar was on stage and I could
stop stripping to me
is performative it's in a weird way it's
common in stripping it's damaged people
entertaining strangers so there's more
of a synergy so I don't really get
anything out of watching the strippers
in the back of my head I know you're
thinking about groceries or some other
[ __ ] but it was hilarious as a comic to
watch two different same but different
type of before it's like the magician
versus the stand-up versus the juggler
and how they all kind of don't really
like one another for one reason or
another because they all think what they
do is superlative to the other guys
craft mm-hmm and it was it was goddamn
it was [ __ ] hilarious
that is a inside scene that only
strippers can really appreciate what
you're talking about you know what I
mean yeah like for them they're like yes
those [ __ ] really in it coming over
here a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] there's
there's a couple of strip clubs and I
used to go to in Birmingham where like
you know the club will close it too and
the police would leave and then at 3:00
the club it reopened and then the
absorption season you knows whatever you
want to do and then you would see
strippers in the parking lot yelling at
the other strippers who were choosing to
stay for the 3:00 a.m. session saying
that y'all are messing it up and that's
why nobody comes before two is because
of what you're doing and so it's just so
three I became like a brothel
yeah yeah it's insane isn't it hilarious
that you could [ __ ] anybody you want for
free and there's not a law about it but
as soon as money gets exchanged you're a
criminal and everybody's mad at you if
you're just a [ __ ] no one but if you
want to [ __ ] people for money that
becomes a real problem for people
because people desire sex so much and
there's so many guys that cannot get
laid but they've got some money and if
they find out they could pay for it I
think people like nope you can't you
can't pay for it you could pay for
everything everything that's legal
everything else that's legal you could
pay for except sex you could pay to have
someone cook for you you could pay to
have someone rub your back you could pay
to have someone cut your hair you could
pay to have some oh you on you can pay
to have someone take out your trash you
could pay to have someone clean your
house all things you don't want to do
you can't pay for someone to suck your
dick you can't then someone could do it
for free if they like you there's no
problem it's very strange
or in exchange for college tuition you
can't even do that if you made like a
deal like you suck my dick and I'll give
you a house people go hey you can't do
that that's prostitution very strange
right I mean think about all the things
we do that we don't want to do but we do
it for money everything's fine there's
no issue even things like you know I
grew up doing terrible construction jobs
I'd never want to do you know might be
better suck a dude's dick for a thousand
bucks then don't look at leader I will
[ __ ] carry cement bags all day for
$400 for a whole week
[Applause]